[Music]
hey everybody it's Monday we're a little
late I'll blame it on me went a is
normal
I'm Eric that's Jake how's it going
we're gonna check out a game I came out
last week I think it was Friday yeah
which is Fire Emblem warriors it's on
the switch uh we're about what like
Midway maybe not Midway but you're in
Chapter eight yeah for four hours I
think it's probably a little less than
Midway okay third all right but you were
telling me that there's a like some
characters that you got now that are
kind of important I don't know anything
about my that's a cannon lightly kind of
the one of the draws of this is that it
combines all the fire room games like
usually there's no repeat characters and
any fireman games got a whole new cast
and what this does kind of like farm
heroes which was mobile you can
basically team up with all of those
characters okay so it's like the big
mashup essentially this is your way of
playing all these characters in one go
pretty much yeah that's awesome
and so when you play for the story it
gives you certain characters you have to
play actually if you go back to those
missions they must hurry back their
portal or is so right now we're are you
playing uneasy someone else I can bump
it up it's actually pretty easy so next
one I'll bump it up someone's mussina
mussina what is in this I have what's up
Andrew just if you guys didn't know I'll
be checking out YouTube chat twitch chat
GameSpot chat so if you guys have
questions or anything like that
hit me up oh actually I put the picture
in picture in the bottom right but if
that's not a good spot I can move it I
think what's okay as long as because the
map is over here if you don't have the
map this is like the most important
right yeah it's one of those like
dynasty warriors that's why it's
warriors yeah which I'm not very
familiar with it all yeah so we'll see
how it goes that's what I was putting on
easy because I've never played any other
ones but like they're pretty
straightforward yeah like I can spot
like I was saying
Letran wants to know is this game worth
buying and the time I think that depends
I I'm a huge fireman fans yeah so I like
it because there's a lot of fan service
for the fire emblem for the fireman game
yeah and it takes a lot from the Fire
Emblem series that I think works
particularly well okay the whole game is
about commanding your army so it makes
sense in a setting like this
however the the gameplay is samey it's
kind of grindy yeah yes I was like so
from that perspective like from a
warriors perspective I was going to say
like some people find it kind of like
relaxing and like to just kind of like
beat a bunch of people up and yeah
destroy them and just feel like really
powerful whereas some people don't find
that gameplay as interesting but I
definitely know there's some people I
want to say like Dave jus it was like
can't wait to like you know hop into a
war like this Warriors game hopefully
I'm right sorry Dave I'm wrong just so
he could kind of like do some very
simple-minded just like beat a bunch of
people up feel good about it and then
call it a day yeah this does add things
that are specific to firemen like you
kind of been tactical we just okay there
you go I was gonna say let's just skip
yeah I was saying like map deployment
like I can tell like I want you to focus
on this command or whatever and I but
like when it comes down to it okay
easier difficult it's still there it's
still there but yet this game is I mean
it is relaxing like I play like a couple
I'll play like two chapters or whatever
then I'm like alright I'm done for now
and then I'll come back yeah but like I
said I feel like that's the kind of
style this has for those people that
enjoy the Warriors serious type games
and like you said like if you're into
Fire Emblem there's a good chance you're
probably buying this unless you really
hates the combat or the the game the
gameplay mechanics of it but like just
in terms of like the fanservice like
just seeing kind of like the whole
roster and playing as those characters
and kind of like a different way right
it's pretty cool Andrew Cortes is asking
me how do I feel about the do
which i think is great as long as it
plays well I haven't played it I've only
seen it I heard it's pretty solid but I
want to see it myself I really liked
doom and I played that on console and
even play it on PC which is probably
even better expands but missions start
look at you on your dragon yeah nice is
there like a chain there's like a chain
combo system right there I haven't
unlocked too many of the combos okay oh
nice and of course this oh yeah I like
it dude I'm liking it I mean like you
said a couple missions it might get a
little old but you know hey like for
like a good we'll say we're doing like
an hour to 90 minutes I think it's fine
I think it's fun to watch so one cool
thing that you can do I'm not sure if
you can do these in other Warriors games
but you can pair up with other heroes
which is huge in in the newer Fire
Emblem game right
if I team up with DeRozan that would
improve their bond and same thing with
this
so I chewed up with Lissa right now so I
can yep that's another Warriors type
thing really so so it like it really
fits with the final stuck it so it works
out okay good board captain ain't got
nothing yeah and like pretty standard
like I mean your main objective is tape
report yeah I like that you can do a
comp like a duo like super that's fine
yeah if you're not if you feel like this
isn't gonna do it for you like it's not
for everyone right but there's
definitely a demographic I think that
likes Warriors game so like if you
somehow like Warriors games and you like
fire and mom I think this could be a
good one yeah also it's on the switch so
you know you could take it on the you
know on the go on the bus and stuff like
that's that's gotta feel pretty good
maybe a long day afterwards yep yeah I
use my mind go go lolly what the axes
long turning boss what up what a badass
he's got bone arrows yeah he's an outlaw
Jake
oh now you're another character yeah so
I switch characters and it looked like I
was like another part of the four yeah
so is there a lot of the like is there
always one person that's mounted and one
person that's not or in this story it
seems like they try to keep it that way
okay
[Music]
Go Go Liana so Lily Anna or Liana and
Alex
they're a tad bit absurd of protagonist
for this and they even specifically
asked for okay but all the other
characters you get I'm pretty sure maybe
there's a couple that aren't so far I've
seen character from awakening and
ooh
see you guys oh yeah she got like kylo
ren's all right I like these coins that
got G's on them being Spock poins
done lowered video yeah that boss was
pretty strong along Tran they're like
crafting there is is there's a lot so
you can buy new weapons for weapons and
then there's it's kind of a lot but I
don't like it's there if you really want
to get into yeah yeah yeah that's cool
more systems yeah like for me personally
has it felt like that different though
like when you bought a new weapon or
like crafted have you crafted anything
that no I haven't okay and when I do get
new weapons hasn't felt two differents
just like a number oh and I think the
weapon they're holding is different
it's all about efficiency yeah I'm all
about that improv okay so this is a
blonde effect since it you've just
strengthen your bond here how does that
influence a your game play it all go off
there I haven't figured that out yet I
don't know if that how that does it does
you unlock things as you do it like
after like and this one they rank up
their relationship it'll it goes up to a
and then it gets a plus I think they
have a little like special conversation
but each time it ranks up if you did I
think therefore upgrade and that move is
so good yeah DMACC x200 said just made
it to the final boss how far is that
roughly DMACC I think Jake's in chapter
4 chapter 8 this chapter chapter 10
sorry for hours I think for at 4 hours
was what my head was what do you think
pray 8 hours 10 hours do you know how
long the game is I have no idea about
almost 5 hours
nice or are on too slick says that this
is the second game they're gonna get on
their switch once they get one ooh
what's the first one
I don't know I'm gonna watch this duo
cutscene oh yeah oh and there's more
yeah doesn't end damn alright so you got
to go fight the big boss guy in the
corner gotta fight the big RKO theatres
in the bottom though and whatever you
guys want to see the KO meter cuz I can
can move us he's at 676 if you're
curious items unlock sound files
character models and my okay TI mine
design ru height for Odyssey I'm pretty
sure there's a lot of people hyped prada
seat there if you guys didn't know this
is gonna be a crazy week part of the
reason why we're a little late to
streaming today we had to kind of like a
bit long meeting about all the games
coming up this week Assassin's Creed
origins Wolfenstein 2 and Mario Odyssey
all coming out on Friday insane actually
me and Jake will be I think I'm allowed
to say this I'm just gonna say it and
ask for forgiveness if I'm wrong but
we'll be on a stream tomorrow 9 a.m. so
come back for that it'll be one of those
games soon is that you think that's the
biggest enough where I don't get ya
that's enough so we'll be back at 9 a.m.
Pacific tomorrow which is about almost
three hours before right now if you're
on a different time zone
the KO meter fills up we get it yeah
that's very good I don't know some
people like numbers I like numbers yeah
it's satisfying when you see like how
many people you have beated I'm more
about like that Devil May Cry style
though we're like it kind of like forces
you to keep chaining your combo so like
you don't want it just like you don't
want that action to stop so you're
always trying to like frantically get to
the next guy I'm but it probably doesn't
matter as much in this game because
there's guys everywhere yeah you start
to learn like some some of the combo
nuances and whatnot and also like you
said there's like skills that you're
gonna you can eventually level up as
well yep yeah sure your favorite
character no we've seen uh okay oh you
guys are all going after this guy looks
like badass yeah it's got book pops
collar yeah
is it dark night I want to be a dark
night yeah exactly
buoys got fired
Wow let me check out the chat here the
game has been getting elites I'm not
sure if you're talking about Mario but
it possible Mario for sure I think like
refuse for oh yeah I mean that edge one
came out like Dark Knight with the crazy
Power Stone kind of an awkward angle
he's still there there is oh yeah I'm
messing around though
oh what's this
another weird camera angle right sorry
oh yeah level up
[Music]
I don't think it's that Matt he asked if
it was gonna be workin standing around
I'm saying too much there's only two
left
yeah so are fun saying yeah tomorrow
artist he's the one getting a lot of
weeks I'm not shocked by that I guess I
mean they shouldn't be doing that
like we're not allowed to do that
obviously I mean we all I always joke
about yeah I'll just do my Odyssey and
then I'll get fired
no it's not happening alright that was a
mission nice yes
[Music]
slow stretch I'll take that ah Wow all
right I see what you're doing
Japan
Oh apparently you can spin the camera
around at any point right stick says Ken
rule rule io9 doing stuff like that
that's what he says at any point so I'm
I'm only reading what chat saying I I'm
I just have to agree with chat until
they fail me which has happened before
why they outright lied
oh so now dark and night baby so pretty
much every character you see you can
typically eventually like a choir oh
yeah make it a making a sec next one
normal do we want let's go to convoy
welcome give me one Chris market here
alright oh so so this is kind of the
upgrade tree you have a lot of heroes
right now yeah there's where's that
Lucena yeah I don't think I get to be
hurt my next mission though but the one
after and the so now what just keep
going will progress will upgrade her
since our finale says I heard this Fe
warriors is bombing because people wife
Lou are not in the game I thought are
not all the characters not all the
characters in there I know actually I
don't know I won popular white blue
characters are Jen I don't think she's
in this you need the waifu's yeah but
there is Lucina
which that's enough for you the center
waifu i don't know if she's my waifu but
like she's a pretty popular character
got it okay
ken rule rule i oh nice as in gameplay
in game
maybe he's telling you to spin it before
you'd be the cinematic probably yes or
maybe during hard cornering I'm not
gonna read that but uh maybe she are you
know different sized than Laura's I
ended up reading can you scan this we
don't need to talk this is not what
we're here for
well it not me at least I mean I tried
to follow the story when I started
playing and yeah just like a something
interesting okay that's fair we got a
question from Matt pepo so what are your
guys favorite Effie characters in this
game warriors so far well you have that
many I think you just said Camila though
I mean in that's I really like I really
like lucena
and I really like Crom which are kind of
like the poster children ders of
awakening and that is my favorite
fighting game so it's pretty obvious
this guy's my favorite Takumi is pretty
cool as well he's in Bates now the other
thing that was weird is he told me
beforehand I'm not a fan of the English
in the in this in a lot of these games I
prefer to switch to Japanese which he
apparently tried yeah right one of the
first things I did was try to change it
to Japanese but I didn't see the option
there and maybe I was in the wrong
option but I with languages and I'm
pretty sure Japanese and you said what
other languages were there there was
German French English and so if someone
knows how to switch it potentially
Japanese and we're crazy tell us but you
know oh thora is one of the DLC
characters oh really
according to Mario towbar thank you for
that information
did you end up switching anyone for this
this mission or now saying it should by
itself since you don't really have at
least in what I've seen you don't have
they're producing poison fogs Jake you
best watch out what's a fire bucket
happy birthday if it really is your
birthday if not you just got me to say
that and I feel like I got toys such as
a way of reading chat sometimes pretty
sure you need to download the Japanese
da from the eShop and then you can
select Japanese that's what's siren oh
that makes sense because I thought I I
thought I saw the option somewhere while
I was playing uh-huh but I couldn't
it was great out that would make sense
where are you heading here I'm trying to
make it through this fog area to get to
the green but I don't know how to get
there they are producing fog after all
yeah there were some guys that had a fog
over their head I don't know if that's
the people that are like producing
excuse me flanking no problem
you got a dragon man it's like Game of
Thrones when the Dragons show up you're
like well what the hell do we do red
scorch if you're talking about this game
Fire Emblem warriors is already out it
came out last Friday something you can
go switch to playing on so if you're
interested and yeah as mentioned this is
a crazy week for game so we'll be
streaming a lot of the big games that
are coming out and we're also gonna be
doing a destiny to launch stream
tomorrow with a special guest it's on PC
coming out tomorrow I was hoping that
our PC code that we got today would
actually work today but it's a global
launch tomorrow so stay tuned for that
but we'll also be streaming at 9 a.m. me
and Jake I'm just not sure if I'm
allowed to say which what it is so this
thing just to cover my bases I kind of
denied one of them so really it's like
one out of two but not all day tomorrow
I'll blog just for like 90 minutes I was
hoping to do it today but
seesee supports
again she's gonna be damned if you don't
because you like pink so many yeah
I didn't spoil its playing tomorrow
there's a 50% chances spoilers
all right there goes inside it falls
gotta get rid of the regular 9:00 a.m.
spoiler alert it any like you know what
timer
bond with Leo has strengthened the Dark
Knight I'm all about that magic kind of
curious how that plays out like if you
were to control we go and what his new
sets would be because it seems like it's
all like it seemed very magic case yeah
I unfortunately the only really
completely now
can rule I says IKEA saw some people are
leaking Mario Odyssey spoilers online so
Nintendo are gonna react even more than
the partners and timeliness look at
gallop away them all like how they just
keep getting combo'd as you like go
forward
I like that so this is kind of how he
would play by roughly earlier right it's
somewhat different but in terms of the
elements he'll I have that's cool
oh yeah scoop them up off the floor
oh is that I don't know
uh redneck gamers knife Anna this Fire
Emblem I mean obviously with the
Warriors tag you should kind of know
what you're expecting it's not like your
traditional Fire Emblem game obviously
it's gonna be played more in the warrior
style but just in with some of the lore
I guess a Fire Emblem or at least the
characters I would be honest I was
disappointed when they announced this
because I would like an actual fireman
game but they announced that too so yeah
so I mean this is just something for
another yet set of people that want like
I said like some people like Warriors
games
some people like Fire Emblem and
Warriors games so it's a perfect for
them you know definitely not for
everyone I know some people that don't
like this kind of stuff like one like
that's a good question okay yeah as as
she says now
home run that's like on your team right
this guy okay to all the fog John now
man Marcel was liking the gameplay so
far but that dragon and horse riding
when stuff seems a bit rigid I think
it's too bad seemed fine
yeah no I mean it's as I would expect I
guess it's like I wouldn't even say it's
rigid it's just like it's super fast but
everything kind of moves fast
yeah I mean there's there's always been
a lot of but the horse stuff has been in
a lot of the worries and it's how you
get from like one point to the other
very quickly to you right was the last
Fire Emblem game you played I played
fakes well I mean Santa's sorry so
faiths before this this is warrior
terrible one and how is that it's fine
things pain but yeah I played a lot of
things is there a two-player I doubt it
there's to play oh there is
no I'm good
take both of them I'll let you just do
your thing because we got to record this
hot gameplay for Nick anyways to your
left there is split-screen co-op in the
switch version yep thanks rich ninja
Jake just confirmed that I don't think
I've I haven't played it I don't know
what it looks like I don't think I
removed play that I think you just
review the switch version ok so
apparently solar dragon says there is
two-player but the frame rate takes
quite a hit I could see that yeah for
sure I mean even some of the moments
here I see it dip a little bit depending
on what's going on Wow
do you find that annoying yes ok I was
gonna say like it's kind of weird to see
all the level ups as you and stuff while
you're fighting I feel like it should
just come postgame where you're like ok
you leveled up for this and then show me
all that stuff because I feel like
you're when you're in the middle of
combat you just want to like keep going
and not get stopped by the fact like oh
great I leveled up yeah it does get
annoying especially early on when it's
like teaching you everything like still
get like three slashes in another thing
with
I think I'm asked that for the most part
as you see it okay just minor
fluctuation nothing you're really
getting annoyed about okay well we could
try maybe we'll do a co-op at the very
end or something yeah I don't see how
that goes but for now we'll just
continue on a little bit through the
story here and give me those GameSpot
coins oh they just disappear yeah I
don't know why they're everywhere take
reinforcement I like how he was the bad
guy like last mission yeah like yeah
guys you guys are real strong the plot
thing is that happens it happened at
least four or five times is that you'll
meet a couple new characters and you're
like oh we can help you and then their
friends are come up to me like you
kidnapped our friends and they're like
no we didn't and then don't attack an
army on you great
my people wants to know is there an
option and saying it's like either 60fps
or 1080p so you have option for either
quality or performance I doubt it I can
look yeah we can take a look later Oh
apparently solo Dragoon says that if you
look at the option menus you can
actually disable most notifications
that's good to go thanks for the tip is
there a different storyline or the same
with depending on which character you
pick I know just a question there they
wrote
yeah maybe explain a bit more I know
when you start you can pick I read
between her or the and I'm I'm it's
probably identical okay
maybe like different dialogue yeah can
rule I also telling us that we can turn
off the little thing that's good to know
laser beams must contain ones never been
a fan of the Warriors games and happy he
hasn't spent any time on this there yeah
it's definitely not for everyone
I've never been a huge fan of them it's
not that I don't like them and avoid
them it's just like I just it's not the
kind of game you wanna play I love Fire
Emblem
so I figured I'd give it a go try and
I'm having fun that's good volume is low
says Casius Chad for who Jake me or the
game we're both got to be more specific
to help me out these enemy Ares are so
lacks about attacking you they're afraid
yeah they're afraid
look at this dragon do you want to fight
a dragon when you're just a foot soldier
I sure as hell wouldn't
I mean as she would say her eyes are up
here
sorry I don't know your name that's Jake
on the left I'm Eric hello welcome slow
well depends on the orientation actually
but yeah I'm gonna guess it's Jake's
because his mic is slightly pointed up
so yeah there you get that better that's
why it gonna be better I would see but
that should help if it doesn't tell me
oh you've been naughty
no mercy no no
if you're like mid-swing you're swinging
them upright if you switch to like he
switched to Liana while you're doing
that or does it just kind of like it
doesn't combo that way right
yeah I don't know if it combos that way
I can do it invert your facecam so you
can actually tell people there's no good
but thanks for the suggestion awesome I
could hardly hear Jake with the action
going on I'm guessing you can now
hopefully I hope so I'm not I mean I
hear you better now so I would assume
that that is the case she didn't know
John really always seems I get D's in
strategy after news Varela saying I'll
buy FB warriors when the awakening dlc
is released in spring hoping that the
price drops why is this a full price or
ziad this is a key I'm pretty sure it be
maybe it's maybe cuz you leveled off
[Music]
it is 59 88 on Amazon so yeah basically
a full price game sitting a little bit
of money sent no offense
they're in trouble Jake yeah we got to
turn that off yeah it's all good though
now that we know that's ken rule I said
they got me when I saw Lin was playable
that's how it works they just get most
or all the characters that you want to
play get them into this game and then
you're like oh I got to see what she
plays like or he plays like oh she's
down it's maybe the last one this is by
sigmod say she's just done done oh
really I can resurrect her okay like if
I don't resurrect her she's like don't
bill to play as her ooh
carbo yep
okay still going it's gonna keep going
51 dollars with Amazon Prime says Blade
Runner 0 0 1 1 0 1 $60 really start to
switch $40 on 3ds thanks elegan uh my
people asks do you still play fire Fire
Emblem
Heroes on mobile no I don't play it
anymore
it was fun it was just like I got like
there's certain characters you want and
then it's just like you keep not getting
the characters you want and just get
this heartening unless you want to pay
yeah
soldier goon gives us good tip or just a
tip in general for all of chats
basically saying if you like Fire Emblem
you'll find that pausing the game and
issuing commands bills that itch for
tactics as well he or she used it and
was probably one of the favorite his
fate his or her favorite mechanics in
the game so yes I suppose so we can try
issuing some
[Music]
[Music]
can rule I says do you know you can team
up with another NPC and switch between
them CR / a you've been doing that combo
still Kula says red scorch I don't know
why she did this
I didn't yeah I don't think make that
wall this 51 yep they're on the other
side of the wall
Jacob Jorgensen our Jorgensen sorry I
play heroes and I just saw that
commander Anna's in this game too that
got me excited Anna is in this but I
don't she's not a playable character she
shows up on levels oh I don't know I'm
just saying like is that that's that's
unfortunate then right like or maybe you
don't know that you can yeah maybe a
real later you can but she does show up
and you can like buy things from her mid
match I'm surprised she hasn't showed up
I am reading both chats the one 277 or
z77 I don't know if you actually asked
question I don't think I saw it earlier
but I'm reading multiple chats so if you
guys have questions I'll send them over
to Jake hopefully you can answer them
he's about four hours five hours into
the game we're on like chapter 10
yeah uh Anthony Varela just saying that
the game is a switch exclusive but it's
not first party look at this guy oh well
I guess not such exclusive tribute is on
3ds yeah I mean that's true yeah those
camera angles
ooh
that guy's pretty buff yeah she is
playable you have to unlock her that was
for Anna Anna yeah thanks for etching
Inka you get her from history mode says
motivos Ivan done well it sounds like
you need all if you like Anna as a
character
[Music]
can you freely switch between warriors
yes and the second question is what does
teaming up dude it gives them
well the bond stuff helps just like your
two characters a little bit more and
then you also have those like team like
super combos right above it I think this
should be one yeah but like if he I
don't know if you saw earlier the one
but like he did a combo with your name
was it we know we Anna's dad technically
fake dead right now know that oh this is
dead
then it was we an event yeah early Anna
and you know they'll just like basically
what it looks like is one person does
like a lot lifting up and then the other
character will finish them off with set
other combo how come one person kills an
army because they're that strong you're
the ones who help my family I'll join
your cause pretty much
really go play history mode now should
we go to history mode we can try it I
don't know
solo Dragoon also telling us that when
they combo or when they pair together
they get stat bonuses combos and support
conversations oh is that always her no
it's because I finished it with her okay
I said I'd switch and I switched her and
she was the closest bye I see ya Jake T
same thing every time
cool
yep oh yeah and then also we can check
what it's like to turn off
[Music]
one second
boob says here perv by the way so yeah
you get items when they when their
relationship improves as well I wanna
see if I can change some of these
settings
[Music]
level up oh here we go level up window
off at battle cinematic cemented on
mission confirmation display settings oh
look at that quality verse performance
whoop someone said quality mode was
better for them I'll leave it in quality
since we're streaming and like :
we're not gonna see hold I didn't mess
anything up on this end
[Music]
yup Nicholas naväge innovations
basically saying like he's a fan of
Warriors games you understand that it's
a little bit repetitive but that's what
he enjoys which as mentioned that
happens later red scorch thanks for
stopping by
shady check it out what do we check what
do we check to choose so it looks like I
have to have an item to revive a fallen
cool so yeah she's she's done unless I
can find the item to bring her back and
for someone the chat would know but
anyway should I do history yeah I want
to try history mode
is this your first time oh she joined
into it but I didn't really play it okay
we're about to find out battle starts as
a battle what's a Roy and ask artists
Jeremy in the house
they say close it not
defeat the captains in Cordillera
Cordelia all right
get tactical tactical yeah show me some
hot deployments all right are you good
general yeah just go here to revive
fallen allies you need a collectible
dropped from certain enemies and that
was from my vivos I'm guessing you don't
have that then no smell
yeah so we're probably not as mentioned
the Japanese kind of like boys pack is a
free download but uh as can realize
saying it is a kind of a little bit of a
lengthy download if I'm not gonna do
that at this point because I don't think
you guys want to watch us downloading
voice back start that mission alright we
got a new new uh character here it's
good I think you have him right I have
he is the other character that you see
you either pick between a girl Liliana
or huh uh him yeah do they play the same
then yeah I mean I haven't noticed any
difference that's unfortunate
that's neat she didn't do that from what
I recall I just thought that move look
different the sword some of the sword
swings what's the same what I can do
yeah he didn't have that did he
whirlwind so Dean dude says that game so
I really wish is it Ike or ek I thought
it was Ike okay I got Ike and the
radiance crew was in this game yeah it's
weird that they aren't at least because
of goo Gaston question how does this
compare to the berserk version I would
assume this is a lot of different
characters yeah so if you want to play
as guts go play preserve like the
Warriors version that was pretty cool
though I liked seeing some of the bad
guys and stuff so I could see like I
don't have an affinity for a Fire Emblem
play I had I was like I was more
interested in the berserk one because I
was like I watch the anime like God's
griffiths and stuff like that and that
was cool to me so I can see why you're
enjoying like this one or at least more
interested in this I think that's how it
is like I'm not gonna go out of my way
like even the Hyrule warriors I don't
really play much desire but I do what I
just thought like you know like warriors
sticks fire I'm so well troubleshot says
no I know Roy ruined well we don't know
like there's some other characters that
be worried told us oh he was thunders
dlc he doesn't know okay yeah there is a
berserker warrior style game I think
it's banded aha
[Music]
oh wow at least I reminded me of a bit
of lawyers nobody's done by the same
team we're not though
it's a berserk Musel Musel saying that
right that one came out in North America
on February 21st of 2017 I think was
earlier this year and I think Miguel
actually refused that yeah I remember
what he gave it I think it got up five
this is one point ahead
I'm pretty sure it was Miguel yep Miguel
blood-and-guts it got a 5 out of 10
but yeah crushing dreams crushing dreams
baby so logic didn't like the Berserker
game yep there's also one piece as a
Daenerys Targaryen I did not know the
dragon Queen herself was here but she's
here here's purple though by Fire Emblem
Dynasty Warriors I wouldn't be surprised
if Mario's got to work I guess so I
gotta be here yeah
didn't you have her in your story mode I
do I have it just making sure I'm not
I'm not
oh well that's how the Warriors was
weird I think some people liked it
though yeah they're more shocked that it
worked out I think you don't know I
think it's more that I don't know maybe
it's one of those things like when you
watch a movie your expectations are very
high and then you're like oh that was
actually that bad yeah the game's [ __ ]
you that you think so and really that's
I will go with six just to just to just
like oh wow we're both wrong it got
eight Wow okay yeah so there you go that
was what
oh wait that's weird so so yes got a
seven and then the Wii U one got eight
and that was reviewed by Mikkel again in
2014 there you go
what's up twist games yeah I can also
see one piece being kind of cool because
I like one piece the anime so like being
like Luffy and doing all his like crazy
movies it's what the hell's going on
with that old man oh nothing just power
up yeah yeah Crom go to work oh there's
nothing there I'll still get like 50
kills don't watch ten no kills knockout
yep
and you got a ways to get to her huh
yeah but I need to kill the captain's in
there yeah you do
oh here we go the other one the other
one yeah that was cool yeah that one's
cool all right so I didn't jump up I can
jump down Miguel putting in work yeah
it's true man Marcel philanthropy aka
our Ben Janka said one piece words is
very good and I'm not even into anime
either that's a lie you are in the anime
you're the waifu's you got a shadow
pigeon simulator body pillow that's what
they are right the body pillows yeah I
was gonna call it a waifu pillow but
it's a bird so it's like unless the
pigeon represents the waifu it could I
have no idea
twist games we've been shooting for
about an hour you're not probably gonna
play this through this history and then
maybe I'll co-op with them and then
we'll probably call it a stream I think
you pretty good I do one co-op yeah I do
one co-op see how that goes which mode
did you pick ultimately to be quality
mode I left it at quality I just entered
for the stream yeah yeah that's a good
call good shout and like but we can
should we change it to not quality mode
what does attest it or for yeah probably
she got hot blonde you got a double here
oh is it okay
okay he went up and did almost the same
thing oh yeah
where'd she go though okay I was like
shouldn't her like horse and her be on
the ground there after overwatch
warriors I don't know Kenji
alright chats getting out of hand now
body pillow warriors see that's his
finisher yeah my eyes are down here Wow
alright please it's a die keema curry
that's safe to search in google anime
die keema Kodaka oh that's kind of not
necessarily safe if you're at work don't
search that it's not terrible but it's
also you know it's possible
yeah we're GameSpot now games stop we
don't sell video games we review so
don't get mad at us for bad trade in
values yeah I've had alright so you want
to switch it now - was it performance
yeah and then you're gonna give me one
of those joy Khan's and hope that we
don't break this setup essentially yeah
today is a terrible influence I am so
not
yeah seed Akeem Akira is a body pillow
that's what Hassan said so I was right
should we do history mode he said
probably not it's kind of late been
Thanks
I don't know we can play whatever you
want just give me a joy Khan and I will
do one I've already done so we can pick
you pick our characters yeah well last
chat who they want to see and who they
want me to ruin as a potential man I got
to play with both that's I do both I
guess
is it easier with one I feel like it's
easier with one I don't know I've never
been a fan of the like like this I guess
I just I wear the bun next her to hit
yeah he's the dodge but you probably on
that dodging a use your super sewing
that bar fills up there are is to use
you're like okay would things encounter
this is a click left stick to join
they're not doing it doesn't seem only
good oh wait there we go
okay boom I can leave now I'll leave
actually
Oh set character already you guys want
to see other than Lissa cuz she dead pig
Lucena all right how do i you know oh
you gotta sit these right yeah set a
character who you guys want to see went
on Fredrick some Robin Leo Takumi Liana
Rowan chrome chrome sorry
Cordelia pick all waifu's it looks like
you can only play the characters that
you've unlocked up no now you got Leo
you just added Leo just trying to figure
out where the dragon lady's Oh what we
can do
maybe she's just not available in this
mission so yeah maybe they don't want
dragons maybe you pick one of the ones
Oh No maybe not one of the ones with
this I see Takumi oh she's already there
Oh camellia Camilla someone wanted Leo
I'll play leo hell yeah hell yeah I got
me some magic I'm a Dark Knight did you
get rid of Camilla though yeah we've
seen a Takumi and we go damn I didn't
know crispr arrow is a fire emblems guy
that's toast man X by the way
Crom too late let's get it going too
late here we go
so these do nothing these top buttons do
nothing no our is 2l is the lock on this
icon and this you'll use like you know
and I like powered up for what yeah so
when that charges and hit aren't will do
that I'm gonna be the one that's doing
nothing we'll give you another tip oh
this looks a lot worse
oh yeah it's just like that other girl
oh I got fireballs oh this looks rolled
girl not so great it's because I picked
performance performance over it all
about that performance light but the
frame rate seems okay actually are you
sure we need to win their trust date his
name is Rowan it's not even Alex oh the
dead spikes
there we go we're done what really not a
Dora logo that's I like the okay so this
is just like that other girl that you
were like musing earlier yeah yeah
where are you okay are you going that
way
I'll join you let me give you some
spikes yeah where's my meters I thought
the blood under my life yeah all right
oh it has to be full now so it is cool
it is full nice because that that our
button that one is a oh oh yeah okay let
me throw a big holy [ __ ] would that mean
yeah the that was the spirit bomb if you
guys are familiar with Dragon Ball leo
has a spirit bomb oh I have no idea what
that was that was my ex why there it was
a good choice to go Leo the dark name I
am following you Mussina I'm fast I
should be fast our damn horse
ould be and you'll go fast oh you can
tell me these things this is not
riveting I'm still having fun though
[Music]
you were smoking me in the ko County I
am cuz I got them hot AoE attacks like
this one look at that
I just burn them the cinders Oh what
what you are not afraid of three
soldiers so in awakening this isn't much
of a spoiler so he is like all based on
but in awakening there's like some
time-travel [ __ ] and that is I
believe so it's like trunks 99 TX great
name can you play a co-op the whole game
yeah yeah everything I've played there's
been an option to add another player
I like how they gave you both the many
maps as philanthropy yeah it's good I'm
just following uh my first player oh
where you at now I switch to can I
switch so you can see it closer to you
well you know what I'm gonna do here is
the death ball yeah oh yeah suck them
all up is that just your a that's my
bead oh that is my get rid of a lot of
oh it's only an eleven oh wait yeah it
was only a loving video though so I
can't switch to get to you right no I'm
pretty close to you I think I will that
is you right yeah oh wow look at his
whirlwind thing I'll keep hitting it's
just we can make our own combos Jake I
have to hit him while you're like
staggering them up in the end
oh no they're all push over a barrel
I don't know huh I don't know who we
fought here that isn't a pushover but
you know how did you go back out yeah
well let's try to find Jake okay so kind
of a mess it's not too bad here cousin a
lot of objectives but later
and I you at least spent a little bit of
time to figure out which Dan I have
double your uh okay oh I know
step it up okay these are the games I
cry that like this oh I meant to do it
like farther to the left where there are
more guys which is what you're doing
right now no steal those kills all right
with latina now well she got her
specialty
I'll go use that in a second oh we got a
beef Fredrik yeah that's what he gets
all right cool that guy's a [ __ ] talker
that's crazy
oh man all right I got a new favorite
Lucy next it's more fun to swim a sword
I use magic I guess I'm following you
beating people up until we figure out
what we gotta go
Oh Frederick is where the other folks
are at oh wait you switch the V oh yeah
oh you're a hella far away and try to
figure out where you're at
yeah no no I see I'm looking I'm using
your map key except I'm going the wrong
way so what's going on here did this
what no this way yeah okay Taku me
oh okay so it's this way alright thank
beautiful yeah yeah thank you
we're all the bad guys cuz you know
lucina's got one TV no choice Jake knows
my be man save some for me
alright here's a little story cutscene
oh he looks like a badass
oh yeah destiny armor Houston for you
okay well I'm gonna go buy it in
attendance which in this game I'll be
back later sounds good
this game is out that next-gen cinematic
framerate yeah oh [ __ ] you're hella far
I'm coming
oh you spear bomb yeah is he dead what I
didn't get to do anything it's too easy
let's do another one okay fun I'll do
one later so it's a little bit more a
little more stuff I love it yeah cool
that you can co-op yeah as long as you
don't mind
yeah the framerate in visual I I view it
as a you know it's a little bit too well
we could try switching the thing I have
no idea what it's going to do though
from quality to instead of performance
but I think it's gonna get even jankier
if we do that probably why is this so
popular in Japan best guess uh whoa
Jay's deadweight get out of here I like
tripled his kills he's in triple I think
people just OMB Pete cuz he killed
Frederick jerk I think that they
probably have a strong affinity to
fanservice
I think fanservice is a big thing in
Japan so I'm sure a lot of people that
play the Fire Emblem games probably it's
thatin that mix I think they like the
Warriors games and then they also like
fire
so do we want to Frederick has no
resistance magic destroys of well there
you go see what a cheater man when I
didn't know that that's fine do you want
to do the next story mission sit on hard
all right let's do an old list an older
one I'm hard then yeah why something
let's action though well so we can pick
our carrot all right sounds good
well do like the most recent will do
this desert alright the desert now we'll
do the castle I think this is the one
with no actually no this doesn't want
the one with the poison fog oh I want to
be that guy
Rio ma that guy looks cool anyone that
has a full set of armor is cool in my
book will you be frederick now oh really
alright can't be list about still dead
she's still dead like you rest in peace
hopefully we don't kill through my oh I
should kill someone here huh okay
do we want to see what the chat once
this time we can pick for sheriff
there's chat who do you want to see out
of I don't know who met who we've got a
zit oh wow oh wow it's real thin guys
you can put Frederick in there okay wise
we are doing Frederick Richard probably
keep Leo in case you need magic for some
reason right and gotta be tactical Chad
get Khaleesi in here though you choose
whoever you want yeah I get Khaleesi in
here see you later just give me it was
good knowing you
oh it's this one liking the objectives a
little more important okay
so left to pay a little more attention
that usually what I do is I follow the
green flashing you follow the green I'll
follow you oh yes
wait you're not near me though huh yeah
but you can such characters might be the
character yeah yeah
and characters like if you see a
gatekeeper it's usually worth doing okay
I'm killing a port captain import
captain's because gatekeepers if you
kill them you'll open the gate for
captain's until them you get bored you
feel like there's less enemies because
we're both on this screen you know that
might be it
I don't think I could handle it my frame
rate is going to
ooh Frederic yeah
Frederic baby oh he has no super meter
built up
[Music]
oh he rides his horse in a circle like
stomps on the ball oh we're pretty even
ko count right now slacking I also
switch character if there's a mistake oh
pardon me excuse me
I used to be yeah
oh I opened the door try fill this out
push captain is that worth it oh here
we're gonna use his super oh he just
vacuums everyone in yeah I mean like out
close captions aren't as important but
like okay oh there's a gatekeeper though
so that's good right
Frederick Lee stomping people with his
horse so just button mashing yeah I'm
enjoying it though I'm trying to like
like use my X&Y like differently just to
see if it does a getting rested in the K
okay right now oh alright gate keeper
down progressing there's an outpost
happening I'm gonna switch to the oh ma
nope let's try to switch to Rio MA oh
wait maybe you can't ooh he's got like a
lightsaber oh no it's just a lightning
sword damn what a badass yeah
hi prince of hoshido could I switch to
that guy next mission
Anker surrett assessment
did you not just see him kill three or
ko3 of your friends or not just leave it
to me
that's awkward that we're not using any
of them oh there's dragon people in
there where I'm at now I'm near Rio ma
well they're about to get stomped on
though
yeah stomp on those dragons
oh you can jump with the horse kind of
get him go a little bit rekt here to
really use one of those like health
recovery gems to know Oh full awakening
though recovery
a bomb outside with a mass really okay I
killed a bunch of the weird ribbon
riders here's one more left
Oh switch the Camilla no she got full
life I won't be blamed if
what's-his-name dies oh she got like a
like a fireball yes I gotta kill
together with her damage Oh Jake's
catching up
[Music]
I see where you're at kind of steal
those kills I help you out there
they're the next sports is it we're
behind us or in fact it is but I can
take you higher
whatever and speak kill people yeah what
I do best
no I just came from here
time for some a action
you're missing the shapes here left
all right I've got the port now got
another one yeah I keep doing this
fireball
Oh Frederick my boy there you are
boom come on get it
damn higher for captain now if you're
already too if you want to do that so I
always I do it just like how does it
removes sick are it is here we go
all right therefore I should go get this
other sport
whoa so at the end of the art doesn't
move because he's about to use his sword
oh [ __ ]
sure and then we're gonna use our a
attacks you
so where did you see the art what's that
where's uh where's the neuter photo on
the left
okay no problem gotcha
Oh what we call it here it's here keeper
BAM
and then stop on them
Oh Leo's here to switch to leo here in a
second god
[Music]
boom well she's got a boat who don't
move oh can you jump up
I'll go get that one whoa my framerate
yeah just trying to like get to these
other areas
[Music]
well what's zr+ Y Z ARP is why whoever
you're paired up with you will like okay
did something
man is poor captain your mouth
get them kromm are you in the center one
yeah I'm at the top middle
oh yeah gets beer bombs
dance for captain's got a lotta life
yeah damn Union told me about that I
should be doing that this whole time
comboing with kromm we don't need help
I'm doing something I was expecting
better results Anna yeah mission
complete baby on the heart that was
pretty easy no problem there's no
problem there
Frederick got kind of low though I will
say it's okay no one's dead no one's
dead that's what matters
come on Jake you slacking I know Richard
bear it was like two buttons for attack
you had the super move the powerup move
there's a dodge and then you have like
team abilities if you hold VR yeah ER
with Y brought in kromm he did like a
quick attack so I was using that in
conjunction with my attacks
ETV I mean it's essentially a Wars game
with Fire Emblem characters I mean yeah
it's not gonna change too much so you're
expecting more how do we do what I use
what I took like right at the end for it
yeah I'm gonna say that you didn't
switch characters that's not what it was
I was showing the chat some riveting
gameplay oh yeah we can we can we watch
it there yeah that's very cool well that
bugs me if you do it on hard it doesn't
count as normal that's kind of weird all
right cool
that was Fire Emblem warriors it's out
on the switch you can play that it's
also out on a 3ds I think 3ds is $40
switches $60 roughly it could be a
little less someone set like 51 on
Amazon Prime but yeah thank you guys for
tuning into that stay tuned tomorrow at
9 a.m. we'll have another stream me and
Jake will be here and then at 11:00
we'll have another stream as well that
one will be for destiny 2 PC but yeah if
you haven't fall or subscribe you should
do that so you guys get notified as to
when we go live and also for all the
cool features and gameplay that we put
up what are any last thoughts here I'll
fire on the Warriors for you Jake I mean
I'm really enjoying it but I'm a huge
fan of the series Fire Emblem not
warriors firemen so there's a lot that
fans will enjoy about it but as someone
was saying in the comments like it's
still warriors at the end of the day so
yeah well if you enjoy I had fun you
know obviously like you said I think it
would be only fun for so long like it's
like a nice little 30-minute ish at a
time it would probably be fun just to
get in there beat some people up switch
characters get some cool cinematics
especially with characters that you
obviously you'll like more than I do but
like even for me I was like oh that's
really cool like what the hell is that
you know so Leo yeah Leo spirit bomb in
people so that was cool yeah I had fun
as mentioned before I don't think it's
for everyone obviously but there's
definitely people that enjoy it so
thanks you guys all for tuning in thanks
Jake for playing and until tomorrow
we'll see you guys later
you